19 هجوما في سته اشهر فمواقع ايران
وميليشياتها في سوريا تعتبر هدفا امنيا
استراتيجيا مباحا لاسرائيل مخازن سلاح
قواعد عسكريه صغيره شحنات اسلحه قادمه من
ايران الى مطارات دمشق وحلب كلها اهداف
ايرانيه تعرضت لهجمات من قبل اسرائيل
المتحدث باسم الجيش الاسرائيلي في خياي
درعي قال ان طائرات حربيه استهدفت بطاريه
الدفاع الجوي السوري التي اطلق منها صاروخ
مضاد للطائرات باتجاه اسرائيل في وقت سابق
بالاضافه الى اهداف اخرى في اطراف حمص
واوتسرات حمص حمى حيث يرجح وجود مستودعات
ذخيره تابعه للمليشيات الايرانيه وحزب
الله طبعا المواجهه بين ايران واسرائيل
وجدت حقل تجارب مجاني وملعبا تتنافسان فيه
على استعراض القوه وتسجيل النقاط سوريا
وخلال 12 عاما شهدت الكثير من التدخل
الايراني حيث اوجدت طهران شبكه مهمه من
الممرات الحريه والجويه لتقويه تجهيزاتها
اهم هذه الممرات كان دير الزور في الشمال
الشرقي السوري وطبعا هو الممر الذي تعبر
منه المعدات العسكريه الثقيله من العراق
الى الميليشيات الايرانيه في سوريا
بالاضافه الى المعابر الجويه حيث استغلت
ايران مطارات دمشق وحلب الدوليين بالاضافه
الى مطارات سوريا العسكريه ونقلت من
خلالها اسلحتها القادمه للمليشيات هناك
اسرائيل كثفت غاراتها الجويه على سوريا
بشكل غير مسبوق تعزي السبب الى زياده
النشاط العسكري الايراني في سوريا العرض
التالي على كل حال سيوضح الجدول الزمني
للغارات الاسرائيليه على مواقع ايران في
سوريا نتابع
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات